if you could forget a book or a movie
and be able to experience it for the
first time again what would you
choose book or a movie a book or a movie
that's a tough I would say would I get
the same feeling as when I first saw it
because that like if I Saw The Shining
for the first time now and felt the same
scare that I did back then I'd say The
Shining or um Star Wars Star Wars or
Empire Strikes Back I mean the the cool
thing about Star Wars is now when you
get the new Star Wars you get to have
that feeling of like oh it feels like
the first time watching and then you
know uh cuz cuz there's new stories to
be told but but I would go with Star
Wars the first one yeah yeah jam and
Jenny what's your favorite way to relax
or unwind after a stressful day
ah
um uh smoke some of the reefer do you I
mean I don't know I this is terrible but
let me think uh to unwind is sex sex I
my my mind went to like sex if that's
what it is why not you have sex it
relaxes you sex relax sex puts me to
sleep does it that see it's relaxing Ian
not during yeah but like but that's
relaxing no absolutely there's nothing
more relaxing than having uh uh what
rhymes with for
gasm but then you just immediately for
guys at least it's just like
it it just shuts you down well if you're
having a stressful day too it like takes
you out of the stressful day because
you're in the moment of doing something
that is feeling good and and also con
connection and uh you know and a sharing
of love and then and then at the end
it's very relaxing I mean is that
terrible to say No in fact I may not
even have that for the patrons I may do
that for a question so more people can
hear it why not would to relax I like to
have sex why is that weird yeah that
weird Dana asks what's the weirdest GI
gift you gotten from a fan oh what's the
weirdest gift I don't know if it was a
gift but I had a fan once say will you
send my nickers and I didn't know what
knickers were so I was like ah sure and
then she like gave me some underwear and
I was like oh I can't sign that that's
that's not that's just too weird that's
too weird I had someone asked if I if
she if I'd sign their breast mhm and I
did no I didn't it was a side breast so
I think I did that